with ethical hacking and penetration
testing becoming mainstream and
corporate environments trained personnel
and relevant equipment are in high
demand
the right software framework can be the
tipping point in a hacking campaign
which deals with intricate hardware
one such tool that has become a mainstay
for decades is nmap
when it comes to scanning machines for
open ports and services nmap has always
been the first choice for hackers
being lightweight and open source nmap
has strong community backing and
receives regular updates
let's take a look at the topics to be
covered today
we start by learning about the different
phases in ethical hacking and where nmap
is most valuable to ethical hackers
we learn the basics of nmap and its
purpose during a penetration testing
campaign
next we take a look at the top level
approach of nmap as a scanning tool and
how it conducts these scans on host
machines
moving on
we cover the multiple modes and types of
scans that can be performed using nmap
on unsuspecting users
we also look at some alternatives that
users can prefer if nmap is not
something they are comfortable with
while our live demonstration of the
powers of nmap will help in shedding
light on the topics being taught today
let us first understand where and why a
map is essential
there are essentially five phases in
ethical hacking
the reconnaissance phase is the first
phase of the penetration test
here the security researcher collects
information about the target it can be
done actively or passively or both
it helps security firms gather
information about the target system
network components active machines etc
this activity can be performed by using
the information publicly available and
by using different tools
the scanning phase is more tool oriented
rather than being performed manually
the tester runs one or more scanner
tools to gather more information about
the target
by using various scanners such as war
dialers port scanners network mappers
and vulnerability scanners the
penetration tester collects as many
vulnerabilities which help in turn to
attack a target in a more sophisticated
manner
in the gaining access phase the
penetration tester tries to establish a
connection with the target and exploit
the vulnerabilities found in the
previous phase
the exploitation may be a buffer
overflow attack denial of service attack
session hijacking and many more
basically the penetration tester
extracts information and sensitive data
from the servers by gaining access with
different tools
in the maintaining access phase the
penetration tester tries to create a
backdoor for himself
it helps him to identify hidden
vulnerabilities in the system while
allowing him to come back to the system
to retrieve more data further on
in the clearing tax phase the tester
tries to remove all logs and footprints
which might help the administrator
identify his presence this helps the
tester to think like a hacker and
perform corrective actions to mitigate
those activities
nmap is most beneficial in the early
stages of ethical hacking where a hacker
must figure the possible entry point to
a system
it is necessary to know this before
running the necessary exploits thus
allowing the hackers to leverage any
insecure openings and breach the device
so the reconnaissance and the scanning
phase are the points where nmap finds
the most used
let us now understand what nmap is from
a layman's perspective
nmap which stands for network mapper is
a free and open source utility for
network discovery and security auditing
many systems and network administrators
also find it useful for tasks such as
network inventory managing service
upgrade schedules and monitoring host
and service uptime
the program is most commonly used via a
command line interface and is available
for many different operating systems
such as linux freebsd and gentoo
it is most beneficial in the early
stages of ethical hacking where a hacker
must figure the possible entry point to
a system before running the necessary
exploits
nmap was developed for enterprise scale
networks and can scan through thousands
of connected devices however in recent
years nmap is being increasingly used by
smaller companies as well
nmap uses raw ip packets in novel ways
to determine what hosts are available on
the network what services these hosts
are offering what operating systems they
are running what type of packet filters
and firewalls are in use and dozens of
other characteristics
it is designed to rapidly scan large
networks but works fine against single
hosts as well
the rise of the iot in particular now
means that networks used by these
companies have become more complex and
therefore harder to secure since every
application that connects to a network
needs to do so via a port the wrong port
or server configuration can open a can
of worms that leads to a thorough breach
of the system the recent emergence of
iot botnets like mirai has also
simulated interest in nmap not least
because of its ability to interrogate
devices connected via the upnp protocol
but also to highlight any devices that
may be malicious
now that we understand what nmap is let
us take a look at the workflow of how an
ethical hacker uses this tool in
penetration testing
at a practical level nmap is used to
provide detailed real-time information
on your networks and other devices
connected to them
we have the hacker running and map on a
system with a victim machine running a
standard installation of the operating
system be it windows mac os or linux
the nmap interface will send specially
crafted packets to generate some reply
from the victim machine
the victim machine in return will send
some information back to the nmap host
with replying some of the services and
hosts that are being run on the
computers
nmap allows the network admins to find
which devices are running discover some
open ports and other services this in
turn helps discover the vulnerabilities
and the possible entry points for
hackers to breach into
we are now aware of how nmap works on a
basic level
but the many varieties of cans that
users can run on local machines
let's take a look at some of them
the ping sweep is a simple type of nmap
scan where it pings to all the available
ip addresses to check which ips respond
to icmp protocol
if the users need to know only the
number of ip addresses and not many
details the ping sweep is very useful
it's fast and hence the results to be
known are fetched very easily
the syn scan is the most useful type of
nmap scan which does work very quietly
it sends an syn packet via the tcp
protocol or the transfer control
protocol to all the intended ports if an
acknowledgement pack is received to the
system it is sure that a port is opened
there
no response means that the port is
either closed or not available
here the acknowledgement pack is not
sent back to the system assuming that
the connection is not valid
the scan is not shown in most of the
scan logs and hence it is safe to use
syn scan to identify the open ports
the tcp connect scan is similar to syn
scan in many aspects as it uses the tcp
layer to send packets and is passed to
all the ports
here the difference is that the full
connection is done by setting the
acknowledgement packets back the logs
can easily find the tcp scan and need
more power from the machines to do the
work
but it is more accurate
if all the accesses related to the os
are available to the user it is better
to do a tcp scan than an sin scan as all
the low level and high level accesses
are required for the scan
the network is also loaded more and
hence users must be careful about
overloading the system and the networks
the idle scan is really used to check
whether any malicious attacks are
planned on any particular network
users need not control the external host
but an ip address and a port should be
given to the same
all other requirements are taken from
the scanner itself
the rpc scans or remote procedure calls
are done by hackers to make the system
vulnerable to virus attacks it is thus
necessary to know whether our systems
answer such calls and make our system
open to malware
rpc scan is done to check this by
finding the ports open with certain
commands being run by rpc
the windows scan is a simple scan where
the application scans the
acknowledgement packets received from
the post once the syn packets are sent
if there are any abnormalities in the
ack packets received the scan reports
the same and helps in recognizing which
ports are functioning in a different
manner
the bound scan is used to check the
security in the file transfer protocol
layer
ftp layers mostly do not accept any
packets and once it is rejected from the
ftp layers there are chances that it
might be sent to an internal layer so
that it can access the internal machines
pounds can check this loophole by doing
exactly the same process and identifies
whether our ftp layer is open to
vulnerability or not
the fin scan is similar to syn scan
where the system that sends the packets
receives the response back and it will
be mostly be a tcp fin packet
if the system sends an rst packet it is
a false alarm and users need not be
worried about the same
the null scan is useful for other
systems than windows where the systems
can easily identify what kind of packets
they have received and respond back with
either tcp packets or non-responses
null scans are not useful for windows as
they may not always produce the desired
results
when it comes to looking at alternatives
there is a wide range of free network
monitoring utilities as well as free
open source vulnerability scanners
available to network administrators and
security auditors
what makes nmap stand out as the tool it
and network security managers need to
know is its flexibility and power
there are some alternatives to nmap but
most of them are focused on providing
specific niche functionality than the
average system administrator does need
frequently
mass scan for instance is much faster
than nmap but provides less detail
in reality however nmap provides all the
functionality and speed that the average
user requires especially when used along
with other similar tools like netcat
which can be used to manage and control
network traffic and zenmap which
provides a graphical user interface for
nmap but as an all-rounder solution to
network scanning nobody can go wrong
with nmap as their tool of choice
let's now take a tour of nmap based on
all the things we have covered today
in this live demonstration we start by
learning of how to install nmap on a
fresh operating system that doesn't come
pre-installed with the tool
we also cover the different types of
scans that can be run on local machines
along with checking multiple inferences
an ethical hacker can gather based on
the scan output of an nmap screen
finally we run scans on vulnerable
machines to get an idea of how to
proceed with the outputs we gather using
this tool
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
the first step in our demonstration is
installing nmap
now it depends heavily on what linux
distribution you are going to use to
perform ethical hacking
right now i am using parrot security
operating system
if you are not aware of what parrot
security is or even what kali linux is
we highly suggest that you check out the
videos of those two operating systems on
our youtube channel so that you can get
a fair idea of what they serve
now if you are using any of these two
operating systems and map should come
pre-installed by default
to check if nmap is pre-installed or not
you can just press on applications over
here
go to the pen testing section
go to this information gathering tab
and you should be able to see nmap right
here
now let's say you do not have nmap
pre-installed maybe you're using a linux
distribution like ubuntu or linux mint
or something that is based on debian
operating systems
one thing you have to make sure that
nmap should be in the distribution
repository
once you check that or even if you do
not know if it is present you can just
this command
should be sudo which is to give the root
permissions for installation
apt
apt is the package manager of all linux
distributions that are based on debian
that goes for debian stable ubuntu linux
mint kali linux parrot security and
anything of that nature
apt is the package manager which handles
the installation and removal of
applications in these specific operating
systems once you're here just write
install
and nmap
press enter and it's going to ask you
for the root password that you set when
you install the operating system in the
first place
enter your root password and press enter
again
as you can see it's saying that nmap is
already installed the newest version
since i am running pirate security
operating system
now should you be running this operating
system or even kali linux you should
receive a similar message and the
installation is already done
if you are using some other distribution
let's say even black ox arch linux or
manjaro anything like that
the installation steps will be slightly
different
this sudo apt-install nmap command is
for distributions that are derived from
debian and ubuntu if you want to install
in arch linux based distributions you
have to use their package manager which
is known as bimac
but that is for a different step and if
you want to get ethical hacking the best
way to start is by learning either kali
linux or parrot security
now that the installation is done
we're going to learn how to use nmap
one of the most basic functions of nmap
is to identify active hosts on the
network
we can do this by using a ping scan the
ping scan identifies all of the ip
addresses that are currently online
without sending any packets to these
hosts now to run the ping scan we're
going to try nmap
the flag we're going to mention over
here is sp now these flags are the
different
traits of the nmap scan depending on
what flag we use we can send different
kinds of requests to the host that we
are scanning
now before moving forward with this let
me open another terminal over here and
check the ip address
we're going to write the command
ifconfig and find the subnet in which
this system is present
as you can see the ip address is 192.168
now this operating system is being run
on a virtual machine software known as
vmware the vmware in itself is running
on a windows 10 operating system
considering they are now a part of the
local network
this ip address is of pirate security
and the windows operating system which
is the host system in my scenario
will fall in this particular subnet
so to run our scan
we're going to target
192.168.
72.1
24.
this command then returns a list of
hosts on your network and the total
number of assigned ip addresses
it's going to be capital p
yeah
if you support any hosts or ip addresses
on that list that you cannot account for
you can then run further commands to
investigate them further
as of right now you can see the machine
that is the pirate security
this ip address can be detected in the
subnet
the 192.168.72.1
is my local windows machine that is
running vmware software and ultimately
this virtual machine
the 72.2 is the dhcp server that hosts
the internet connection of the parrot
security this we can ignore for now
now the windows machine that we have
over here let's run some tests on that
i'm going to clear our terminal
and we can close this actually
when scanning hosts nmap commands can
use server names ipv4 networks
or ipv6 addresses
a basic nmap command
will produce information about the given
host
to run a basic port scan we can just use
nmap along with the ip
now as you remember
the ip
is 192.168.72.1
this is the ip of my local windows 10
machine
as you can see
it shows the ports that are opened and
the particular servers that these ports
are running
now we can also have a detection of the
operating system
now mind you this is not 100 correct and
the reliability depends on the
installation
and what kind of fingerprinting measures
are available
now since this does tcp ip
fingerprinting it needs some extra
permissions
the flag that we are going to use is
nmap
minus o
along with the same ip address
like i said since this is tcp
fingerprinting it requires root
privileges
now to provide root privileges we're
just going to add the nmap
and sudo keyword
going to repeat the same command that we
wrote above
as you can see it has successfully
detected that i am running microsoft
windows 10
with this mac address
it has also shown the correct build
number of the windows 10 system that i
am using
this is useful for troubleshooting
scanning for few vulnerabilities or even
locating some services that need to be
updated
look at the necessary information about
these services for example what versions
they are using
we have a command known as sv which
stands for service version
we use the same ip address
and press enter
now as you can see
the scan is complete and if you can
check the results of the scan above here
we don't see any version number for the
services
here we can actually check what version
they are running
now this becomes helpful when we are
trying to find specific versions to
exploit
for example a vmware workstation 16.1.2
had some particular vulnerability
we can exploit it by checking this
command
apart from the host scanning port
scanning is one of the most basic
utilities there are few ways that this
command can be customized as well
for example
i have already checked that the 443
command is open
but i have found out after running this
lengthy scan let's say i only want to
check if command if the port 443 is open
and map i'm going to use the
flag of minus p
which stands for port
and give
443 as an argument here
using the same ip address
and you can see it says it's open
but we already knew it is open
let's say there was something else
uh if let's say we're going to scan if
the apache web server port is open which
usually runs on 80.
obviously since i'm not running an
apache web server it says it's closed
now we can combine these two commands by
running both both simultaneously
to do that
we can just put a comma
and
complete the rest
similarly
expected it is closed and 443 is open
another feature of nmap
for port scanning is showing of ranges
now ranges can be beneficial when you're
trying to see up to a certain limit for
example nmap minus p we're going to
check what ports are open between 100
to let's say 2000
this acts as a range
everything else is the same
and it checks all ports
in the range of 100 to 2000
whatever pose is open in between that
range
it can be mentioned over here
we're going to clear the screen now
another flag that can be used with nmap
is the ss command
this runs a stealth scan which is a
little harder to detect if you're the it
admin of the system that is being
scanned
the results will more or less be the
same although this will need elevated
root privileges
to point one
as you can see this is more or less
similar to a port scan it just adds an
extra mac address as well for good
measure but like i said it's more about
the stealth the normal scans usually are
easier to detect when the logs are being
checked
stealth scans are relatively tougher to
check
on much more intricate systems this
takes longer as well
now that we're done with both scanning
let's look at a vulnerable machine the
system that is scanning right now is
this my own personal system but
everything is pretty locked down as much
as it can be
there is an attack box running
in the cloud the ip address of which is
over here
now to be able to get into this network
we need to connect to their personal
network using a vpn
so what i'm going to do is switch to a
different workspace over here
i'm going to open a terminal
and if you can see over here there is a
hack test.ovpn file
i am going to connect to their vpn
network using this ovpn file
and once we get the initialization
sequence completed message we know that
the connection has been established
like we discussed this is the
vulnerable device ip
we're going to copy this
and we're going to try to ping this
let's open a new terminal
i'm going to try to ping this and check
if we are able to reach this machine
and as you can see we're getting a reply
back which means we are now part of the
local network
where the vulnerable machine is present
let's run a service scan map
with the respective versions
we ran the similar scan on my local
machine where we were able to detect
what version each service was running
what we are going to do over here is by
checking what kind of services are open
on the machine running on the cloud
we're going to decide what we are going
to do next and we are going to see if a
map alone can point us to a direction
where we can gain access to the machine
as you can see the scan is now completed
and we have some of the ports that are
being opened over here and what kind of
service they are running
now
like we discussed this is the first
stage or sometimes even the second stage
of ethical hacking
what we can infer from here is what are
the services that are being run now
these two ports 139 and 445
are actually windows smb server ports
which are
above the windows samba server
now every service has a particular port
attached to it that will be consistent
whichever machine you may use apache
server will always run on port 80 smb
servers will function on these two ports
now assembly servers have had a
vulnerability known as the eternal blue
exploit which was pretty well known as
of right now from the scan results we
are not able to detect if this machine
has the similar vulnerability or not
but since it has the smb server open
it's worth a short that we try that
exploit on this machine
now to start the exploit on this
we're going to open another terminal
over here
and we're going to use metasploit for
trying the exploiter
we're going to write sudo msf console
msf console
is the keyword first launching the
metasploit console
enter the root password and wait for
metasploit to launch
other than the ports we can also see
that it has
checked the host name of the system
and the operating system as well
now that the metasploit is open
we're going to launch the exploit
now before launching we're going to have
to check what exploits are there for the
eternal blue vulnerability
we're going to write use exploit
blue and we're going to check what kind
of results we are getting over here
as you can see
serial number 9 exploit windows smb
ms-17010 internal blue it was first
disclosed in 2017
and assembly remote kernel pool
corruption
let's say we're going to use this
particular exploit
now all of this may be confusing if
you're not aware of metasploit but
remember this is the next stage of
ethical hacking which comes into the
gaining access part
we're going to use
exploit number nine as we found above
to use exploit number nine
we're going to set a payload
which
is our malicious code that will run
on the victim machine
now we're going to check
some options
as you can see it has by default pointed
it to the 445 port since that is the
port where smb server can be accessed
from
the parameter that's missing over here
is our host
the r host is the ip address of the
vulnerable machine basically the machine
in which we want to attack
now i'm going to use the set command
to set the ip address
now if we check
we now have
a victim ipad set
another parameter that we can change is
the lhost this is basically the ip
address of our own system where we are
going to gain access
now if you have remember we had
connected using a vpn
so we're going to be assigned a new ip
according to the vpn so if we write
ifconfig
and check this one tu10 is the vpn
adapter
this is our ip address that we have been
assigned in the server in the network
where the vulnerable machine is present
so we're going to copy this ip address
we're going to move over this workspace
and we're going to set lhost
with that ip address
with that our options are set
now we're going to
run exploit
and it's going to check if
samba server vulnerability is present
as you can see it has written that the
target is vulnerable to this particular
exploit
it's going to send the malicious code
and the mauritius code is set in the
payload that you sent above
and we now have the shell command of the
windows machine
as you can see see windows system 32
to be sure that this is in fact this
windows machine that is being used we're
going to write ipconfig
which is a windows only shell command
as you can see
this is the ip address that was assigned
to the victimize victim machine
now
while the major part of this process was
done on metasploit
we would not have reached the stage had
we not found out that the 139 and 445
ports are open which basically pointed
us that we can drive the eternal blue
exploit of the windows samba servers
similarly
all the scans that we run serve as a
preface to the actual stages or the
actual hacking stages of the campaigns
this sv command was necessary because we
could check what are the exact services
that are being running
in some cases if the if apache server is
being run there are particular versions
which have particular exploits those
exploits will not work on other versions
so we're going to have to check what
particular version is being run and
accordingly apply the exploit that can
be done in the metasploit or you can run
some other tool but
what
exact exploit you have to run and which
vulnerability we have to target that is
where nmap comes to help
hope you learn something new today
if you have any questions or doubts
regarding this please feel free to let
us know in the comments below and we
will get back to you as soon as possible
subscribe to our channel for more
informative content like this and thank
you for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here